You disobeyed orders, acted on your own impulses and
risked the lives of millions of people!
Is this just all a game to you Shinji?!
I don't want to hear your excuses! What would your father think of this?
He doesn’t care! He’s not even here now!
Your father is a very busy man Shinji!
No he's not! He's probably just somewhere laughing at
the fact his son almost got killed again!
HAHAHAHAHA
SILENCE!
Everyone in this organization is risking their lives Shinji! We
all have our roles we have to learn!
Ok Mr Ikari, we will try this one last time.
What, do you see here?
- It's Godzilla!
- Incorrect.
- Its Godzilla!!!!
- Incorrect!!!!
- ITS GODZILLA!!!!!!
- INCORRECT!!!!!
Your Mom?
Everyone here just hates me, nobody cares about me. I’m the
one that always gets pick on! I’m the one that-
That’s enough! If you’re unhappy, then go do something about it.
Oh yeah! Well you know what I’m, gonna do?!
What Shinji? WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO!?
THAT LITTLE SHIT!
Ok new kid, I need you to hit me as hard as you can
- ...What?
- Come on, I decked you the other
day so you need to hit me back
I'm not gonna hit you
I can take it so just do it already!
I don't want to!
We need to do this so we can be friends!
I don’t wanna do it!
- Do it!
- I'm not doing it!
- DO IT!
- NO!
JUST GROW A PAIR HIT ME IN THE FACE YOU LITTLE MAMA'S BOY!
Did you just slap me?
Why, what should I have done?
Rei Ayanami…
No known family, no past records. The girl is just a mystery
Interesting way to say she has the personality of sandpaper.
What happened anyway? How’d she get so injured?
It was during the unit 0 testing phase...
All systems nominal. Commencing unit 0 activation test
Everything was going well, until something happened that triggered the Eva off...
and so my wife said: "I’d rather die than spend another second with you!”
So I was all like: “Ha, Jokes on you! You can go die for all I
care, cause I’ve already made some stupid clone of you called Rei! HA!”
Wait is this speaker on?
Sounds kind of dangerous
Well, the commander was still his usual self
Sir it's dangerous you need to get back!
Relax, I got this
STOP FREAKING OUT YOU STUPID ROBOT!
Aaaaaaand I just shit myself
That still doesn’t explain how Rei got her injuries
Well, after Unit 0 had stopped going berserk, we had to get
Rei out. Normally we’d send a team to extract her but-
EJECT THE ENTRY PLUG!
Oh right...the ceiling. It’s probably not as bad as it looks
She ended up breaking most of the bones in her body
Wow. How’d she take all this?
How do you think?
Rei! You’re Ok to pilot again right?
I hope you die in a fire
That’s my girl
I just don’t get it. How can the commander be
so ignorant? He doesn’t even understand his own son.
Oh please, that’s the way his mind works!
He’ll probably be calling me up soon telling me about
some new genius plan of his or something.
- Don’t say it
- I HAVE A NEW GENIUS PLAN!
*Sigh*
Does this one also involve your son?
No, I heard he didn’t come home last night anyway
Shinji ran away again?
Well stop the fucking presses!
So in the Godzilla movie she was only attacking the
city to find food for her children right?
- No!
- and the army distracted her with fish…
- You're not serious....
- And that means...
You can’t be!
WE CAN USE FISH TO BAIT THE ANGELS!
Oh. My. God.
For the last time sir, Godzilla is a fictional monster!
Maybe that’s exactly what the military wants us to think!
WE ARE THE MILITARY!
Perhaps Dr Akagi would know what to do
That is if she doesn’t want another ride on the Gendo train
What the- …Can you get out of your self-absorbed world for one second!?
What is our next plan against the angels?!
YES!
What?!
Sorry, I was picturing the Gendo Train
Wait...what do you mean if she's wants another ride on the Gendo train…
YOU DID WHAT?!?
Right, I might’ve slept with him
But…he’s an idiot!
Everyone gets lonely sometimes
He shot you in the arm!
So I slipped a little...
and what, you landed on his penis?!?
Oh please, this coming from the person who
keeps herself occupied with stupid brainless toys!
What's that supposed to mean!?
Misato! What's that 9 inch black thing floating in the bath tub?!?!
I’m sorry, were you talking about Shinji or the actual dildo?
You know what, forget it. Here take these.
Just ask Shinji to give it to Rei tomorrow
I don’t think he has the courage to take the initiative
Not his virginity the card! What else could I possibly mean!?
So do you always say hello by pushing people down?
This isn’t what it looks like!
Oh, well that’s good.
Cause to me it looks like I’m naked, you’re lying on
top of me with what appears to be an erection
My underwear are scattered everywhere and you’ve just reached second base.
Have I missed anything?
B-b-b-b-bu
You could’ve tried buying me dinner before trying to have your way with me
Or at least start with some small talk
Oh OK! Sooo ummm…
Nice weather we’ve been having!
That, was a joke. But you do have your hand on my breast
Well this is awkward
Would you get off me?
Ah! Yes Mam!
And you can put away that one inch thing you call an erection.
It’s an embarrassment to penises worldwide.
So wait...does this mean I just got laid?
Sure why not
AWESOME!
Now what’s that polite thing father told me
to say after sleeping with a girl...
So does bitch wanna make me a sandwich?
Rei?
Sorry…..I just realized stupidity was a genetic disorder
I wonder what she means by that...
SO DOES BITCH WANNA MAKE ME A SANDWICH!?
Sir, I am not your wife.
Bitch say what now?
So I’m sorry about earlier
Are you mad?
I feel like you’re a bit mad
You’re mad aren’t you
You mad Rei? You Mad?
I’m not mad. Do I look mad?
Errrrrrrr
Don’t answer that question. In fact just don’t talk to me
Say Rei, what do you think of my father?
Apparently you don’t know what “don’t talk to me” means
He always treats you so nicely!
I’ve heard that father said he always wanted a son…and well, I’m a guy!
That’s debatable
So why doesn’t he care about me?! What does he want me to do?!
Well, have you tried not completely failing at life?
Or you could also laughing at your problems, everyone else does.
I’m kinda sensing that you don’t really like me that much
Take it this way. If I had a dick, now would
be the time I’d tell you to suck it
Are you coming on to me?
An object has been detected entering zone 6
Switch to code red and put unit 1 one on standby
Hey Misato.....guess what I have!
- Is it a Boner?
- Errrrrrr
Cause if you say “I have a boner” one more god damn time
I will come over, and personally kick your ass!
We have visual of the target!
Great, what can you tell me?
The target appears to be…a thing
What the hell do you mean “a thing”?
It’s a…a…thing?
Can none of you three do anything useful around here?
Maya!
Yes, the object is cruising at a steady pace towards central dogma
It’s constant phase pattern gives it a reflective qualities
that makes it appear like a massive….
Thing
Massive thing, I’ll show you a massive thing
Have we at least got an analysis of it?
Analysis pattern is blue
Its...
IT'S AN ANGE-
NOBODY FUCKING SAY IT!
WE ARE NOT DOING THIS AGAIN!
- I have a boner
- THAT'S IT!
What the hell is that massive thing?!
Why don’t you pull down my pants and find the massive thing
Get unit 1 out there!
Affirmative, launch the EVA!
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!!
OH MY GOD, I'M GONNA DIE!!
What the hell are you doing?
This is too good!
I THINK SOMEONE PEE'D IN MY ENTRY PLUG!
Just launch the damn thing
Hold on!
I detect an exponential increase in photo energy levels!
Say that again?
She said Photonic levels are rising!
IN ENGLISH!
WE’RE FUCKED
Oh.....
AT fields at maximum level!
He’s won’t hold out much longer like this!
Quick, deploy the blast shield NOW!
I’M ON IT COLONEL!
How do I do that?
Oh for god’s sake!
- Blast shield deployed!
- Target has ceased attack!
- The enemy has halted the energy beam
- Energy spike detected!
WHAT THE CRAP?!
WHAT THE BONER?!
- WHAT THE FUCK?!
Saw it coming
Quick, execute emergency recovery of Eva Unit 1!
We can’t, the catapult has melted!
Then just eject the plug suit dammit!
Cancel that order!
But sir! Shinji is-
We can distract its motherly urges using fish!
- What?!
- Just.....Don't
Ugggghhhh
Detonate explosive vaults. Get him out of there!
- Explosive vaults detonating
- Commencing unit 1 recovery
- Now evacuating Section 10
- Target has ceased attack
Transferring unit 1 to emergency extraction
Colonel
We need a medical team down here now!
Colonel!
I’m reading a pulse, but it’s faint
- Maximize the life support!
- Yes Mam!
Colonel!!
Get Shinji out of there now!
Roger that
LCL release sequence initiated
AND HURRY!
COLONEL!
WHAT?! WHAT IS IT SHIGERU?!
It's an Angeru!
It's an Angel!
Angel it's an!
It's a Gundam!
OH MY GOD IT'S GODZILLA!